hi I'm Denise hey what's up my name is
taka tomara my name is Jose Herrera
today I'm gonna be guessing the cost of
these tattoos
[Music]
so for pricing a tattoo it probably
varies $20 Sid who's to say I feel
pretty confident about it yeah yeah I
can do it I bet I can get close to it
let's go tattoo number one looks pretty
big so black outlined flower stuff I
don't think this will cost around 300
bucks I would probably say it's about I
have to know I would guess this tattoo
probably cost around 400 bucks oh yeah I
guess they kind of cause it got a deal I
mean it's pretty big it seems like it'd
be a lot of work watery woman it's like
a half sleeve a lot of black and gray
negative space from the shoulder maybe
to the elbow probably say it thousand
dollars again I'm thinking this one's
probably around four five hundred no no
what actually three hundred
let's do three hundred because that I'm
really gonna guess in the cost of the
tattoos okay
[Music]
is age-old favourite dandelion kind of
blowing into birds I've done this tattoo
it before many times I would probably
say like 180 first something like this
my quick guess will be 250 you know what
let's go with 300 all right cool not 200
bucks how do i best guess okay this one
is a script it's hard to read but this
is pretty cool man
I like it the script is definitely a
very specific skill there's artists to
make a living just off of it
so my final guest some probably $300 I
think this will go around just 50 I
would guess this one cost 250 200 huh
little off I guess they saved 100 bucks
[Music]
there are small small tattoos we have an
exclamation point
Justin black maybe like an inch I say 80
bucks for something like this I'm sure
every tattoo shop it has their minimum
so I will go with the $80 I'm gonna say
hundred bucks
Oh depends what you got though you know
I think I'm going pretty good so far
so this is an astronaut with ribbon
around him floating through the galaxy
would you call this guy a marine er what
Al's it again just like the one before
because it seems like it's pretty huge
like on the RHIB a while 18 no 2400 now
there's sense it's almost $1200 yes I
could see oh wow um way off
dude this is very cool
like it keeps in a nine tailed fox or
the chick this is huge it's like a full
sleeve shoulder tourist I have to see
you like a Japanese type of work I like
you know that's cool thousand five
hundred for something like this since
it's like so huge maybe even more
because of the size I will say $4,000
we're rolling here I guess [ __ ] 100 I'm
surprised actually if its massive oh
it's a great deal in Lisbon tell them to
get you something like a little bit bit
doesn't know your hand like a hand size
honestly it's huge it looks like it's
maybe it's whole by dying photograph
old-school Americana style all this
probably $500 price say 500 bucks for
something like this
mm-hmm this was probably like 500 bucks
okay so it's $1,000 so that's really
awful thousand Wow good for you good for
you
person is super light looks pretty and
doesn't seem like they get a lot of Sun
one will go for four hundred three
hundred and fifty dollars 250 now
there's a lot of color which I guess oh
it was close
all right fine whatever I don't think I
did that well it's kind of cool seeing
another you'll charge is horrible I
didn't do as good as I thought I would
do it's difficult I haven't troubled
pricing my own tattoos so that was
really stressful you know it's a hard to
price of tattoos because you are selling
your piece of yourself in the way how do
you even like you know put the price
[Music]